all right good morning
be seated everyone hope everyone had a
good evening
all right mr blankets you ready to
proceed yes
call your next witness please
defense calls lisa campo
all right lisa campbell please officers
[Music]
uh just remain standing for a minute
please place your left hand on the bible
raise your right hand my cold clip will
administer an oath to you do you swear
in the presence of almighty god that the
testimony the city court regarding this
matter shall be the truth no truth and
nothing but the truth yes please state
your name your last name for the record
lisa campo
c-a-m-p-o thank you all right have a
seat miss campo
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it does not
in any way project your voice in the
courtroom if you don't understand the
question please indicate that i'll have
council rephrase all right very good
mr blancas your
good witness miss kendall come on
what do you do for a living
um as of today i'm retired
directing your attention back to august
7th
what were you doing
i was working as a physician assistant
at marstown medical center and can you
give the jury a little bit of your
background
i was employed at morristown hospital
since 2009 i worked in the orthopedic
department and covered orthopedic and
orthopedic trauma patients
directing your attention to
august 7th
did you have an occasion to treat
michael barrasso
uh
not that i recall
but according to
the notes
yes
i'm going to show you
what's been marked
d 600-2
and i realized it's a couple years ago
can you uh take a look at those notes
and tell me whether or not
that refreshes your recollection as to
whether or not on august 7th
you were working and
treated michael barrasson
according to this uh yes i'm the author
of this note i was
present in a trauma room for a trauma
patient which arrived in the emergency
room
i was doing a consult for the orthopedic
surgeon who was on call for trauma
looks like at the time the patient came
in he was not identified
therefore the note says that the patient
is 119 year old unknown and that's
typical for someone who is a trauma
patient to come in until they are
identified at some point
down the road
all right so
now whoever you were treating on that
day
did you notice any
injuries to him
according to the note
the patient was complaining of elbow
pain
it says that there was
multiple abrasions scratch marks about
the chest back and left elbow
with regards to the physical exam
and in talking to him
what if anything did you know
i noted that the patient was awake
he was only oriented times one which
means he
would recognize his name other than that
he was confused he
if he was not oriented more than times
one that means he really didn't know
where he was or what date it was at the
time of his arrival
i wrote in my note that he was confused
and speaking and complaining of
significant chest and left upper
extremity pain distress
did you notice any
puncture wounds on his body
according to my note it says there was a
puncture wound and scratches a left
along the left a dorsal elbow
and a
significantly obvious deformity of the
elbow
with regards to the chest what did you
observe
i see no obvious deformity
there were multiple scratches and
abrasions and a possible puncture wound
in the left flank
i've nothing further
cross-examination is campo you don't
specifically remember treating mr
barrison no i did not no further
questions children
all right thank you ma'am you know
just one other question irrespective of
whether or not you remember whoever you
treated on that specific day
you observed what you've testified to
correct absolutely yes
all right you may step down miss campo
thank you
the next witness mr valencus
audrey hubert
audrey hubert
just
good morning good morning can you place
your left hand on the bible please raise
your right hand my core clerk will
administer the oath
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
please state your name us by your last
name for the record andrea everett huber
h-e-b-e-r thank you
have a seat man please keep your voice
up nice and loud
the microphone on the witness stand does
not project your voice at all it just
records it so we need to hear your
natural speaking voice
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase all right very good
mr blancas your witness thank you good
morning
good morning
um what do you do for
i am a director of a non-profit
organization in long valley the mbca
um directing your attention to
august 7
2019 yes what were you doing
i believe you're referring to these
first aid squad call i'm a volunteer
member of the long valley first aid
squad
so
i was
going to the call
okay and how long have you been a member
of
that first day uh to this point 18 years
18 years as of now now
all right so approximately 16 years at
the time
correct
and if you have any particular training
to be a first aid responder yes i'm a
certified emt
in the state of new jersey which means i
did
at the time i went through the class was
about 110 hours of training
uh 10 hours of volunteer time at the
hospital and we do continuing education
classes to recertify every three years
on that day
did you respond to
a 411
mill road
east or west mill yes okay and
when you got there did you have an
opportunity to observe
my client michael barrasso yes
did you treat him on that day yes
all right
with regards to
your primitive
your primary
impression
do you recall what that was at that day
may i look at my notes sure absolutely
well let me give you your report it's
defense 600-1
take a look at that see if that
refreshes your recollection we're going
to be talking about certain things right
uh we got to the scene
um
there was a lot of activity
um
the person that came with me in my
ambulance went to treat the young lady
and ice
they had enough people there so i looked
over and saw mr barriston sitting
against a tree
with an obvious facial injury
okay
and did you observe any injury to his
arms
um
i saw that in the report yeah i did not
recall that before i read the report but
yes
now that you've read the request
what if anything you observed with
regards to his arm
that came a little bit later um
as i stated he was handcuffed at the
time
the initial
my initial observation was the blood
that was running down his face
um the arm
we tended to a little bit later when two
members of the atlantic
ambulance squad came over because i
didn't have enough equipment there
and how would you describe what you
observed regarding his arm
i don't recall
it was deformed
um
and we did splint it later
according to the report but i did not
it didn't stick out in my mind honestly
as much as the facial injury
okay um
do you recall seeing any injuries to the
inner
left thigh
there was it looked like a dog bite
and where was that located
in her left thigh along with various
lacerations
now
during your treatment of him
did you ask him what happened for the
purpose of
using that
as far as your assessment
i don't recall
do you recall him saying
she georgia recall
she can refresh her recollection you
can't just read from the report the
report's not in evidence okay can you uh
please look at your report yes sir and
i'm going to refer you to the second
paragraph in the narrative
did you ask repeated questions to mr
barroso
no sir he asked repeated questions to
the crew
okay and what do you say if anything
about the incident
i don't remember
clear i don't remember everything please
refer to your report and see if that
refreshes your recollection oh he
remembered his birthday at one point
he did not remember the incident
just so the record's clear mr bolinkis
was pointing
it's to refresh your recollection
reports not in evidence does it refresh
your recollection about
what he said regarding remembering the
incident
not really but if i wrote the report
it's true one okay okay i have nothing
further
mr shalhorn miss huber what does uh loc
stand for loss of consciousness
and did you indicate in your report on
the top
section that there was a head injury
without loss of consciousness correct
no further questions judge thank you
where was that information where did you
get that information from
that you put in your report that there
was a loss of consciousness we have
a um
system
where that we use for writing reports
and there's a drop down menu and that
best described what the incident was
okay
but but specifically the uh you
indicated
there was not a loss of consciousness
not that i could no yes and is that is
that determination based on your
interaction with mr barroson at the
scene or do you get that information
from other sources as well
to put in your report
i don't recall honestly your honor what
transpired as far as my asking your
questions it is a question we usually
ask
but i don't recall specifically asking
it in this case
somehow i knew either somebody told me
or mr garrison himself told me okay all
right thank you
you can step down man thank you so much
for coming to court today
find your next witness please
dr john
dr john
hi doctor good morning
can you place your left hand on the
bible please
and raise your right hand you can put
your pen and notes down that's it raise
your right hand my clerk will administer
enough yeah do you so in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony goes to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth yes please state your name
as for your last name for the record
yeah john daniel bascara
b-a-s-c-a-r-a
you may have a seat sir okay
please keep your voice up nice and loud
yes the microphone only records it does
not project your voice anymore okay all
right and if you don't understand the
question please indicate that i'll have
counsel rephrase
go ahead mr blancas
good morning doctor
where were you employed sir morris
county correctional facility in what
capacity i'm the uh the jail
psychiatrist
and how long have you been with john
since uh january
2016.
now
can you give the jury a little bit of
your background
your education and experience
prior to
august 2019. yes i completed my
uh psychiatry training in 2004 and uh at
uh thomas jefferson university
and uh in 2006 i finished my
child and adolescent psychiatry training
at
new jersey medical school here
directing your attention to august 20th
2019
did you have an occasion to
talk to my client michael barrasso yes
yes
and and
uh what was the purpose of that
discussion oh
uh it was um i was referred uh by the
staff uh because
um
this guy if i refer to my notes yeah who
had been complaining of stuff
did you um author a report doctor
oh based on your interactions with the
defendant yeah and was that done
uh around the same time yeah
contemporaneously with your interactions
with the defense
yeah after i saw it yes and do you need
that to refresh your recollection about
specifics of your interaction with the
defendant yes i have a
okay all right we're going to have that
has it been marked mr balance just for
reference uh for the record
what's the exhibit number
600-6 okay
as a psychiatrist
um
did you ask michael barrasson about the
events
that occurred on
august 7th 2019.
um
yes yes was he able to remember or
respond
to your questions regarding the actual
event
uh well um
he told me that he couldn't recall what
happened
no further questions
mr shalhorn any cross
dr bascara can you describe the nature
of your examination
was it a forensic examination
no was it a clinical examination yes yes
yes and and how did you gather the
information that you needed to treat
michael barrasson on august 20th oh we
just met in
the examination room and um
as as based on
his self report his is
the interview and based on your
conversations with him did you note any
delusions with his thinking
uh no no no
did he mention anything during the
course of the interview with you about
being fearful or scared
yeah let me just refer to
uh
he just each said that his
he had been very nervous you know his
mind was racing with whatever
yes
did you note in your report uh that he
was acting apparently impulsively with
this recent violent behavior
well this that's also based on the
report just uh of what he told me
what happened
right so so you wrote that based on what
he told you yes you you indicated that
he had apparently acted impulsively and
violently
oh did i put that in my mouth
yes yeah yes
where it says diagnosis yeah
what does that mean where it says rule
out amnesia due to head trauma
uh no it's just
because one of of the two complaints one
was anxiety the other one was
forgetfulness so just a
just a
you know a possible explanation for what
he's saying no further questions judge
all right
any redirect mr malinkas
you may step down doctor thank you
members of the jury did anyone have
trouble
hearing any of that testimony
what was it the entire testimony or just
parts of it
yeah
very soft-spoken
you want to bring him back and have it
uh repeated mr shellhorn the jurors
indicated that in here the last couple
of questions he answers
i would certainly defer to the jury if
they want him to come back otherwise i
think the
they can certainly ask for that to be
replayed if there's any question during
the course of their deliberations
unless they wanted to come back we can
have him come back now that he's here or
everything's recorded so if you need to
hear it we can have it replayed during
your deliberations i i leave it up to
you how would you like to proceed
i'm happy
okay
all right it is all the testimonies
recorded you've heard me say that a
number of times so and if you need any
specifics of testimony during
deliberations you can always ask for a
playback and we'll have it played back
okay
yes
your next witness
thomas fellini corporal thomas fellini
hi corporal good morning uh please place
your left hand on the bible raise your
right hand my court clerk will
administer a note do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony considers court regarding this
matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
please state your name spell your last
name for the record thomas colleen
last name's african frank a l-l-e-n-i
thank you
all right corporal have a seat
please keep your voice up nice and loud
we have jurors in the first two rows
that need to hear that microphone
doesn't project your voice it just
records it so okay they need to hear
your natural speaking voice all right mr
blinkist go ahead thank you uh where are
you employed sir washington township
police department and how long have you
been employed
uh 20 years
directing your attention to
uh august
7
2019
uh were you the appian of the search
warrant concerning this case yes it was
can you can you explain to the jury what
an action is
an atheist is
an officer who collects all the
information from the incident that
occurred
responds to the prosecutor's office
fills out an affidavit
stating what uh
what is required to investigate the
incident
and
we draw up
an affidavit of warrant
and a judge reviews that
signs that and that enables us to
collect the evidence we need to
do our investigation
in this particular case
you were
conferring and consulting with the
morris county prosecutor's office
correct correct
and and after that consult
you swore to and submitted your
affidavit correct correct
now
did you request
to search any vehicle based on
the information that you had had
yes
what vehicle and who did it belong to
it was uh
can refer to my absolutely
is
yes it is
what if any vehicles
did you request to be searched
that's the um
the silver dodge ram pickup
with the floor registration
and why did you include that in your app
today
it belonged to uh
the suspect
mr barrison
and um
were you aware that there were
two other vehicles and a trailer
parked in the immediate area
close to michael barrasso
yes
did you attempt to get a warrant to
search those vehicles
no he did not
did you request
to search
various telephones
yes
and
what telephones were then
there was a black
samsung galaxy s7 who did that belong to
based on your knowledge
uh robert goodwin
any others uh yes there was a white
iphone with a pink case
believed to be uh belonged to lauren
canorack
and then there was a white iphone with
no case
um
weren't sure who that belonged to it was
in the area of the incident
it was in
another iphone that was taken from
mary haskins gray at police headquarters
did you request the swapping
of any person's hand
for a gunshot
um
yes
yes
and
whose hands did you request
he suave
uh michael barrisson
and why did you
request
that michael barrasson's hands be
swabbed for gunshot residue
due to information at the scene
um we were
advised that he was the shooter
and and what does gunshot resident have
to do with michael barrasson's hands if
anything
it would uh
prove that he had shot a weapon
did you ask to
swab
any other person's hands
on that day no
to your knowledge was any gunshot
residue has been done on anyone in this
case
no
i don't believe so
now
in your affidavit
you put information that you received
from various witnesses correct
yes
and is it correct
that you indicated that goodwin only
let me see inside
corporal did you talk to robert goodwin
yes
and did
robert goodwin tell you
that he only heard it again
again this is your witness
you can't lead your witness
what did robert goodwin tell you with
regards to
whether or not he actually saw versus
hearing
the gunshot
i have in my affidavit basically what he
had uh stated to me that day
about him he was on the porch
and
he turned to enter the residence
and heard a gunshot and turned
back
and looked
at him back or turned around
turned turned around
turned to walk back into the residence
reportedly
lauren can iraq walked over to speak to
embarrassment by whether this is
refreshing his memory or whether he is
it appears he's reading and i don't know
if that's from his memory or not
are you i'm referring to my report
to refresh your memory or do you have no
recollection of it you're just reading
from the room there's a difference i was
just reading i'm sorry my recollection
would be that he
explained to me that
he turned to go back into the residence
and then
heard the gunshot turned back and
observed
uh mr barrisson
shooting lauren
no further questions
cross-examination
yes sir and that's a copy of the
affidavit that you submitted to judge
ironson on august
7 2019
correct is the information contained in
that based on a full and complete
investigation
it's it was a quick investigation at the
time in order to get the information i
needed to
uh quickly
obtain the info
the rest of the information through the
affidavit in other words you can't
conduct any search at the property until
the judge authorizes a search warrant
yes correct so you didn't take the time
to conduct a full and complete
investigation before you submitted this
to the judge it was just based on what
you knew at the time that's correct
now you were just asked some questions
about speaking to robert goodwin
yes where did you speak to him
i was in front of my patrol vehicle at
the scene and can you describe what your
recollection of the
scene was was it chaotic
yes were there a number of police
officers there yes both from washington
township and other agencies correct
i believe chester one of the chester
police departments was there at the time
i believe so uh
the morris county sheriff's office
correct a number of different ambulance
companies yes
and
did you see ms cantorek had been shot
yes did you see her receiving medical
treatment at the scene yes how would you
describe mr goodwin's
emotional state at the time you were
talking to him
um
i i was tending to miss kanorak when i
first got there
and when she was taken away is when i
went to talk to mr goodwin
um during my care of miss kanorak he was
frantic trying to get to her and one of
officers was
basically holding him back and speaking
with him to keep him away so we can care
to her at the time that you were
speaking to him at the scene in front of
your patrol car
was he somewhat difficult to follow what
he was saying
uh yes he was still frantic she was on
her way to the hospital and he just
wanted to get to her
did uh did you record that statement
uh no i don't believe so uh are you
aware that he was taken from
the scene back to the police department
for a formal recorded statement yes
i think you were also asked the question
about
making an application for
a search warrant
or permission to search specifically the
silver pickup truck
correct and was that based on
information you received during the
course of that limited investigation
that michael barrasson had driven to the
scene in that pickup truck yes
in your affidavit did you
ask in paragraph five
for
authorization to search
any other items relevant to the
investigation and crimes described
herein that a complete and thorough
search will reveal
yes so you didn't list every single item
vehicle location on that 50 acre
property
in this search warrant affidavit no i do
not
just based on what you knew at the time
you applied for the search warrant that
afternoon what you were specifically
aware of that needed to be solution
correct
no further questions judge thank you
what any redirect yes
corporal with regards to this catch-all
phrase the prosecutor just uh
brought to your attention
to your knowledge did you ever search
robert goodwin's vehicles or his trailer
no
to my knowledge
even though technically you could
based on
well
let me see that side more
is it your understanding
that that
you can search
a vehicle unless it's specifically
mentioned in a war
what's your understanding you're talking
about the the
the current application you're talking
not not generally just he's asking you
about the current search warrant
affidavit and the warrant that you
received the one that i received that
gave you the authority to search robert
goodwin's two vehicles
and the trailer on the property yes
to your knowledge were they searched
that i could not tell you
um
did you did you
[Music]
seize the camera
that was looking directly
at the location objection yeah you
missed it mr blencus
just just ask a question don't
editorialize please did you put in the
affidavit to search things and seize
things
any cameras
yes
to your knowledge did they seize any
cameras
no
nothing further
you may step down thank you this is uh
yes just think that the council will
retrieve it
i'm gonna get this
[Music]
oh thank you
you're honored the defense calls jamie
dancer jamie dancer
can we be heard at sidebar sure
yes
all right uh we'll call the witness
officer if you would uh miss jamie
dancer
amen just remain standing for a moment
left hand on the bible if you would
raise your right hand listen to the oath
do you swore in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name
spell your last name for the record
jamie dancer
d-i-n-c-e-r thank you all right have a
seat miss dancer please keep your voice
up nice and loud in response to
questions that microphone does not
project your voice it only records if
you don't understand the question please
indicate that i'll have it rephrased
go ahead counsel thank you ron
miss dancer good morning good morning do
you live in new jersey i do where
millstone township uh and are you an
athlete
i am in what sport dressage
and how long have you been a dressage
athlete
since i was seven so
30 some odd years and could you give the
jury a brief summary of your
accomplishments in that field
i'm a usdf
bronze silver gold medalist and
i've recently started competing
internationally
did there come a time when you became
acquainted with michael barrisson yes
and what year if you recall
approximately was that
2003
and
what was the nature of your acquaintance
with him in 2003 going forward if you
could summarize that for the jury
i first started working for him as a
working student
and then after that i started my own
business and
would continue to ride with michael and
ship up to his farm in new jersey and
also
down in florida with him
did you train with him as a rider
yes
did your horse train with him yes
in connection with that training was any
of it accomplished at the farm in long
valley yes
uh did you live at the farm
at points yes
so let's fast forward to 2019 were you
living at the farm at that time no were
you still training with him yes and was
your horse still being trained by his
business yes
uh and then any part of that training
was it conducted by other people that
worked in the business
no okay
so
you knew michael as a trainer correct
yes did you know him in any other
capacity given your involvement with him
over those years
we're friends and he's my mentor
based upon your friendship with michael
over the years do you believe you've
developed an understanding of
what he was like under normal
circumstances yes
could you describe for the jury what
michael barrasson was like under normal
circumstances yes
he was very clean cut
shirt always tucked in belt
everything was always clean and
immaculate everywhere
um fun to be around
um
yet
when it came to the riding very intense
and precise
um
i
yeah based upon your years of experience
knowing michael barrison did you have a
chance to observe him working with
horses yes did you ever witness him and
enter in any manner mistreating a horse
no
given your experience with him over
those years did you ever
observe him being violent toward a human
being
absolutely not
were you on the farm in early august
2019
yes were you coming and going in
connection with your training yes
uh during those days well are you aware
that an incident occurred on august 7th
of the fall yes are you aware that there
was a shooting yes okay
prior to the shooting is the next series
of questions that's what i'm going to
ask about okay
um were you observing
michael barrisson's
behavior at all in the days leading up
to the shooting
yes
uh how is he acting in comparison to the
michael that you knew from all of those
years before
he was very upset he was distraught
i was very concerned he was going to
harm himself
when you say harm himself in what way
were you concerned that michael barrison
was going to harm himself i thought he
was going to kill himself
did his appearance change at all in
those days leading up to the incident
yes what changed about his physical
appearance
he was pacing
he wasn't as he did like his shirt
wasn't all the way tucked in
um
no belt
um
like
uh
sorry i just need a minute take as much
time as you need um
just not him he wasn't him he was it was
hard
to talk to him i was
concerned about him
was he less communicative than before
yes did he look disheveled in any way
personally in his appearance yes
and you say pacing tell me more about
the pacing that you saw
um
it was like neurotic it was like
neurotic pacing it i can only compare it
to horses um which
they pace when they're stressed and they
and they're looking and they're
searching and they're just unsettled
based upon what you observe with michael
barristone did you come to any
conclusions as to whether he was
stressed
yes he was stressed and did you come to
any conclusions in your own mind as to
how you felt the degree of stress that
michael was under at that time extremely
high extremely high
as a result of your observations of
michael or pardon me let me back up for
a second
did you make any of these observations
of michael the day before the shooting
which would have been august 6 2019 yes
and as a result of your observations and
what your concerns were did you take any
action
i did what did you do
i called my good friend ali brock all
right and i don't want you to talk about
what was said on the conversation okay
okay
so you talked to ali brock
yes
uh
and did you walk away from that
conversation with any understanding as
to whether ali brock was going to take
any action yes and what was your
understanding that you walked away from
that conversation with objection
what's the nature of your objection mr
shellhorn here's a judge or call spray
here say a response
objection sustained
uh questions withdrawn
had you uh based upon your observations
on august 6th of 2019 had you ever
before in your association with michael
barrisson seen him in such a state no
and
i have no further questions of the
witness
very good cross-examination mr shellhorn
ms dancer you weren't at the farm on
august 7 2019 were you no you don't have
any personal knowledge of what happened
on that day no no further questions
judge thank you all right
no redirection you may step down missed
answer thank you
[Music]
your honor our next witness i'd like to
call is allison brock
what
allyson brock please
hi miss brock
please remain standing for a moment
place your left hand on the bible raise
your right hand
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name
must follow your last name for the
record allison brock b-r-o-c-k thank you
all right you may have a seat miss brock
witness has been sworn
counsel direct examination
good morning miss brock
good morning
um
where do you reside what state
i'm in florida
and uh
uh
what town in florida
uh specifically loxahatchee okay
and um uh are you an athlete i am in
what sport
uh in the sport of dressage and how long
have you been a dressage athlete oh
25 years
at least
and um could you give the jury a brief
summary of your accomplishments in that
sport
yes
i was a member of the 2016
rio olympic team for dressage for the us
and we won a bronze medal
so i've competed internationally
at the highest level
was that team usa yes
was michael barristone associated at all
with that team yes what was his
association with that team he was my
coach
and uh prior to him coaching you at that
event how long had you known michael
barrisson i met michael in 2002
and in what capacity did you
first start interacting with michael i
actually um i lived on his farm in 2002
i was working for susan blanks who
was an another olympian
and
she was in the process of going through
the selection trials for the 2002 world
equestrian games i was a working student
we had horses at michael's farm
ahead of the selection trials
your familiarity with michael uh did it
start in some capacity where he was
training you
not at that time i didn't start training
with michael until 2010. okay but i
lived on the farm so
i was there
on and off that summer
did you know justin very well
when i got back i went to europe with
sue and when i got back justin just
started working for michael
so starting in 2010 that's when you
began to train with mr barrison yes
uh and uh
how long after that did you continue to
train with him really through 2016
and then my
top horse
um was injured in rio and never came
back and i had a bunch of young horses
so
i would see michael here and there but i
wasn't training like i was leading up to
the olympic games
did you also get to know michael in any
capacity other than as a trainer yes
i would consider michael
a close friend
um
in
august of 2019
where were you physically located i was
actually
driving back from a vacation with my
family in the keys
and
at that point in time let's just bring
it to august of 2019.
did you receive a phone call from jamie
dancer
i did
i'm not going to ask you to tell us what
words were spoken in that call
because it will result in an objection
so the questions i'm asking you please
do not interpret that they that you need
to respond in specific words
all right
so you spoke to jamie dancer that day
yes do you recall approximately how long
the phone conversation lasted
um i it was a couple minutes because i
was in the car with my family and i
didn't want to have a discussion
with them in the car
uh did you take any action as a result
of your conversation with miss dancer i
did as what did you do as soon as we got
home and i could separate myself
privately
i called michael
did you have any particular concern that
drove you to call michael that day
absolutely what was your concern based
on
what jamie had said to me and
and texted me
um i was very concerned that michael was
going to kill himself
so you got michael on the phone
yes
without telling us what words were
spoken how was michael when he first got
on the phone
well he was quiet which
was very unlike
michael
and started to
tell me about objection judge
try not to get into the words of the
subject
so he was quiet at first
and then
proceeded to
[Music]
get more
and then was sobbing
hysterically
by the end of the phone call
were you able to calm him down at all no
in the past had you viewed michael in
circumstances when he was upset
yes but nothing
nothing like this you anticipated my
next question
based upon your years of knowledge and
experience working with michael and
knowing him as a person had you ever
seen him
in the state he was
or a partner seems probably not the
right word had you ever encountered him
in the state he was as of that phone
call
no further questions at this time
cross-examination mr shellhorn ms brock
you're a member of the board of
directors for the u.s equestrian
federation i am and you're a member of a
number of different committees with the
respect to that association
beyond the scope of direct
goes to a background which you elicited
in some detail council i'll allow it
uh ms brock you were not in new jersey
in august of 2019 no you were not at the
farm on august 7 2019 no and you have no
personal knowledge of what happened that
day no
judge i have no further questions thank
you what
no redirect your honor you may step down
ma'am thank you
sorry
[Music]
what next witness
sean cullen
walk up to the table returning
[Music]
place your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand
please listen to the oath
do you swim in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
yes i do please state your name i'll
spell your last name for the record sure
full name of sean cullen last name is
c-u-l-l-e-n
thank you all right you may have a seat
mr cohen please keep your voice up nice
and loud you can remove your mask if you
want to i leave that entirely up to you
but if you keep your mask on you're
going to have to speak
that much louder so we have jurors in
the first two rows
all right very good thank
you no none at all
all right mr cullen has been sworn go
ahead sir thank you
um
mr cullen
where are you
atlantic helps us since
can you give the jury a little bit of
your background
sure i'm a licensed professional
counselor within the state of new jersey
my degree is in accountant master's in
counseling psychology
i've worked in behavioral health for
just a little over 20 years now
and i have an extensive history of doing
uh
psych valves interviews in er settings
and
where did you go to school uh coldwell
university
now directing your attention to uh
august 9th
did you have an occasion to
meet and talk with my client michael
barrisson yes
and at any
point in time
did you try to ask some specific
questions
regarding the event
in question
specific questions no
not about the event
okay did he make any statements with
regards to the specific event yes what
did he say
he spoke as was cited in my
documentation he spoke about the
stressors of the event
some aspects in the days before the
event
to my recollection and what's in my
documentation you do not recall the
immediate events that result in his
being in the hospital
nothing
cross-examination
thank you judge
mr cullen uh when you met with the
defendant on august uh 9th of 2019
did he indicate to you
that he had told the police that
things at his farm were going to come to
a boiling point
i believe there was a quote in my
documentation from that day from that
interview with him
and if i judge if i could just approach
briefly
with his report yes sir all right what's
the marking on it as s 84
35 and 37 of s84
mr cullen that report is just to refresh
your recollection at this point just
take a look at it tell us if you
recognize what that document is yes your
honor is that a report that you authored
that is correct you recall the date you
authored the report yes
and does that um in essence summarize
your interactions with mr barrissone on
august 9th yes
thank you
go ahead
and
mr cullen directing your attention i
believe it's uh about a quarter of the
way or a third of the way down that
first page
did you put that
excuse me probably a little bit further
down the page than that did you put that
in quotation marks uh that this was
going to come to a boiling point
judge i i object i yesterday read the
entire sentence it's out of context
again
just object mr blinker
i don't like
mr cullen i think the question i asked
you was uh if you could read the direct
quote that michael barrasson told you
from your report if that refreshes your
memory
certainly the direct quote in quotations
as i kept telling him this was going to
come to a boiling point
now did he also didn't he also tell you
on that day that his significant other
didn't feel safe
uh that is correct that's also in the
documentation there's a quote for that
as well
he never told you anything about he
himself not feeling safe
it's the best of my recollection that
was not quoted directly to me
did he also tell you that around the
time of the shooting that
dc pmp or child protection was at the
property
yes according to my documentation the
wisdom noted to be the morning prior the
dcp were present and did he tell you
that there was a specific
reason that dcp would he was there was
for a call pertaining to the care of his
girlfriend's children
to the best of my recollection he
mentioned that he felt that someone had
called them making possible accusations
as they arrived due to concerns to
investigate
did you note
that he said to you a number of times
that there was a steady building of
stressors in his life
yes that is noted in my documentation
and i believe if i refer you to page
three
did you indicate that he noted several
acute stressors in the 48 hours
preceding
his admission to the hospital
yes that's
correct but you didn't specifically note
that fear was one of those stressors
not specifically in my right to my
recollection not that i quoted in the
report
last question mr cullen uh you found
mr barisson's thought content to be
unremarkable for delusional distortions
that is correct
judge no further questions thank you all
right any redirect yes
with regards to the quote that the
prosecutor read you regarding uh
i kept telling them
this was going to come to a boiling
point
who did he indicate to you
that he was
telling this to
several times
the local police department
were you given information that he
possibly
had ptsd
ptsd is listed in quotes in the
documentation
for the service i work on the
psychiatric counsel service when a
physician puts in a consul order they
always put a rationale for that order
that was the initial rationale by the
medical team
and
did they also
indicate that there was a complaint of
loss
of consciousness
that was also that's quoted in in my
documentation that comes from the
medical notes
with multiple trauma status correct
that's correct
is there any
notes with regards to a left elbow
dislocation
judge i'm going to object that this is
beyond the scope of the
cross examination
it is somewhat details
i can
bring out other details based on his
cross
all right i'll allow it
overall
did it indicate that there was multiple
traumas to michael barrasson
per my documentation the medical
documentation yes
open reduction left elbow dislocation
correct
that is correct that's from the medical
documentation
nothing further
anything further mr schallenhorn
all right mr cullen you may step down
thank you let's watch your stuff please
so
all right call your next witness
your honor the defense calls jordan
osborne
jordan osborne
place your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand
please listen to the oath do you swear
in the presence of almighty god that the
testimony you give to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes i do please state your name
must go your last name for the record
jordan osborne osborne thank you all
right ms osborne you can have a seat
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone does not project your
voice in the courtroom it just records
it so the jurors in the first two rows
and then the jury box have to hear your
natural voice all right thank you if you
don't understand the question please
indicate that and i'll have counsel
rephrase
what
this is
i'm good how are you i'm well thank you
for asking
um
as of uh august 2019 how old were you
i was 16. you were 16 years old and did
you uh
live at the farm in long valley where
michael barason operated his business
yes i did
and what did you do there
just in general that summer i was a
working student so i wrote and i helped
take care of the horses
and so give us an idea of what your
daily regime was in in life back in
those days um we'd get up and we'd feed
the horse's breakfast and then by then
it was time for everyone to ride so we'd
help get horses ready we'd ride our own
horses
we'd then we'd feed lunch keep riding
eat dinner and then just normal regular
barn chores cleaning things up
were there other students living there
as well yes
and who were they
um there was chelsea westra
mike mike mcgrain and cassandra defranco
and then justin was there as the
assistant trainer
and um was cassandra a student or did
she have some other capacity there um
she was a barn manager so with
everything taking care of the barn and
the horses she was in charge of that
and were you aware uh that there were
other people living at the farm in the
farmhouse in the summer of 2019 yes i
was who were they lauren canaric and rob
goodwin
and did you interact with them at all on
a regular basis yes i did uh you're on a
request to approach the witness
sure
i'd like to show you a photo
which has been marked as d
800-90
do you see the photo yes who is it a
photo of that's rob goodwin
and
uh does this photo
uh depict uh goodwin's appearance as you
understood it to be back in august of
2019
yes all right move 800-90 in evidence
objection
i'm not sure what the relevance
all right the objection is sustained
move on to another area council
did lauren cataract and robert goodwin
have a dog
yes
and did you interact with the dog at all
not physically hold on hold on
we had a problem with court smart
that's the recording
all right go ahead counsel
just re-ask your question please
did you interact directly with the dog
not physically but i saw the dog a lot
i'd like to approach
i've shown you i'm going to show you
what's been marked for identification as
defense exhibit 800-90
does that picture
in your mind an accurate picture of the
dog
yes what was the dog's name
uh rosie were you scared of the dog
objection
what's the relevance of this
while you were on the farm uh commencing
in the period of the end of july we'll
say july 31st
uh through august 6th
were you aware of whether or not the
police were called to the farm on a
number of occasions yes
and did you ever talk to the police when
they were at the farm yes i did
when you talk to the police
did you observe their reaction to what
you were telling them yes
and what reaction did you observe of the
police when you told them
the information you get
they were very
nonchalant and they just turned around
and walked away
did you ever feel threatened by robert
goodwin uh objection judge we just
talked about this all right members of
the jury we're gonna take our all
morning break now
[Music]
you can step off the stand
just watch
[Music]
[Music]
you